[Musique]
je m'inscris
je peux payer avec la carte
j'ai vu sur la voie
d'une carte c'est un peu spécial mais
je vais payer ses lacets ça ok merci
beaucoup elle salue tout le monde j'ai
vu sur mon tik tok en échec et que sais
je me suis baladée il ya des chaussures
de oufkir victoire que vous avez la tête
et a été super cette année tête et hop
tu t'es martyrisé toute l'année on est
d'accord tels les l'isi c'est un cadeau
de ouf c'est pour toi je vais choisissez
temps noël tu vas halluciné ces cadeaux
vas-y vas-y oui j'espère que ça va lui
faire peur
regarde regarde
tu kiffes dans ça c'est ça a cartonné la
fashion week c'est le nouveau design de
des crocs et tout méchant c'est un truc
de ouf
ça ressemble
fois
[Musique]
heureuse
je vous racontais un truc que vous savez
peut-être pas au sujet des hôtesses de
l'air et des stewards a régulièrement
tous les deux mois tous les mois enfin
ça dépend du planning on est amené à
faire ce qu'on appelle une réserve de
quoi en fait celle de réserve c'est un
peu comme être d'astreinte ou de garde
sait pas trop comment on appelle ça
c'est à dire que on est amené à venir à
l'aéroport et attendre qu'on nous
déclenché sur un vol pour remplacer une
notation estimant qu'ils seraient
absents ou absente donc en gros tu t'en
sors ça veut dire que nantes analyses tu
as nounoune pull gorgoni tongs shorts
crème solaire bail parce qu'en fait tu
sais pas où tu vas partir le jour même
il peut partir sur les i au chaud 30°
cacao je voulais dire notre coco ou
alors à new york à 25 décembre c'est
cool oui il fait moins 20 et la tête
bien content d'avoir foutu une doudoune
haute analyse donc voilà on arrive à
l'aéroport on attend à laon badges ont
dit voilà je suis là et j'attends
j'attends un petit d'un petit message
qui me dit tu par apple en droit et
parfois on n'est pas déclenchée donc on
rentre à la maison et le lendemain on
vient jusqu'à ce qu'on soit déclenchée
de réserve
et puis
ici noël